الحياة على الجزيرة قريبة من السهولة ، وهي
ليست المكان الذي تأتي فيه لتصبح ثريًا ، ولكن
الأمر يتعلق بنمط حياتنا ، لذا فهو
أسلوب حياة أكثر سعادة ،
فنحن قلة من الناس في أيرلندا ، يتعين على
الجميع الحصول على وظائف متعددة لمواصلة الاتصال
وأرضية يمكن لأي شخص آخر الحصول عليها
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بك في شمال فرانسي ، وهي جزيرة نائية صغيرة
تقع قبالة الروافد الشمالية
لاسكتلندا ، موطنًا لحوالي 50 شخصًا ،
ومنارتان ، ومطار ، وبعض الماشية
والأغنام ، وبعض الأختام ، وهذا
ليس كثيرًا من القوى العاملة ، لذا أثناء
تواجدك في البر الرئيسي  لدي وظيفة واحدة ربما
وظيفتان هنا ، الأمر أشبه بستة أو
سبع وظائف قابلت سارة مور ، اسمي سارة ،
لدي عدد غير قليل من الوظائف في الجزر ، أنا في
المنزل كارا كلارك إلى المجلس المجتمعي
أعمل في معالج الأمتعة بالمطار ،
وهو رجل إطفاء  لقد حصلت على قطيع
من الأغنام ، أنا جزيرة فاوستيان
، لقد كانت الوظيفة حقًا هي أحد سكان الجزيرة الذي يقوم
فقط بالتجريف والمساعدة في
القطع والقطع المختلفة وليس يومين
، كما يمكن أن أساعد
في تربية الماشية يومًا ما وإصلاحه  سقفنا
في اليوم الآخر وهو كل ما
لا يحتاج الكمان إلى مساعدة ، لكن مجرد
التخلص من لوجان 727 شمالًا يساعد أيضًا
هنا عندما تكون درجة الأمان 184 درجة
هي الأولوية الأولى ولا توجد صلصة هنا
لحسن الحظ لم نواجه حالة طارئة أبدًا ،
لذا نأمل الاحتفاظ بها  بهذه الطريقة ، انتقلت
إلى الجزيرة قبل ثلاث سنوات
ونصف ، لم أكن أستمتع بالحياة
هناك وهناك الكثير من الأشخاص ويمكنك أن
تمنح أي شخص أي شخص تكون
مجهول الهوية تمامًا كملكة تتبع مكاني
هنا ، ثقتي هي  اكتسبت بشكل كبير
لأن الأشخاص الذين يأتون معهم
يعلمونك المهارات التي تحتاجها ،
قلت إنني لم يكن لدي قط خراف في إدنبرة ،
مرحبًا معظم الناس لم يفهموا تمامًا
أنه عندما أرى أنني حصلت على
ست وظائف ، فهي ليست ست وظائف بدوام كامل.
النجوم هم من العمل ، نعم 24
ساعة في اليوم فقط من أجل رضائي الوظيفي
في نهاية اليوم ، يمكنك معرفة ما إذا كنت
قد أنجزت شيئًا بالفعل
بدلاً من مجرد أنك فعلت الشيء نفسه
أو الشيء نفسه في اليوم ،
كم عدد المنازل التي يجب أن تعيشها  يستغرق الأمر
، أعتقد أنه شخص ما مثل 25 منزلاً في
أيرلندا أقوم بتوصيله لبضع ساعات ، وهذا
يتوقف ، وربما يكونون قد توقفوا مؤقتًا
لنسيان أن هذه الجزيرة ساحرة حقًا ،
أعني أنها فريدة تمامًا بطريقتها الخاصة ،
فلن تجد أبدًا مكانًا مثل
هذا هو المكان الذي يمكنك أن تأتي فيه
وتعيش بالطريقة التي من المفترض أن تعيش بها ، فأنت تعلم
أننا محكومون بالطقس على
عكس الساعة وليس لدي أي خطط للذهاب إلى
أي مكان أقوم بإعداد الجذور
وسأكون هنا حتى  أموت
[موسيقى]